- All right! We always leave a little time
at the end of the show
to spread some more joy.
This is What I'm Liking.
(cheering)
- So not long ago,
a Virginia math teacher, named PJ,
was out at target with
some friends, as you do.
They were taking some videos of them
just dancing around and having fun
and then they tried something new.
They decided to spontaneously
pose with random strangers,
which is great. It's
fantastic. Check this out.
(electronic music)
(cheering)
People be ready for the moment y'all.
They were like, oh wait, I got this.
That's like, everybody's ready
for their moment on camera.
It's amazing.
The moment PJ posted the
videos to TikTok, they blew up.
Cause they're awesome.
We have PJ on the line right now,
along with his friends, Kitrel
and Amir. What's up y'all?
(cheering)
- Hello.
- How you doing?
- Oh my gosh. Y'all are so funny,
but PJ, tell us more about
how this all happened.
Who just decided to be like,
hey, let's just do this?
- So one evening, like
Thanksgiving weekend,
me and Amir right here,
we went to target and made
our daily content, you know,
dance videos, everything was good.
And all of a sudden Kitrel
and Lamont walked up
and they joined us like,
you know, made dance videos.
And then Kitrel came up
with a brilliant idea
and he was just like, let's walk around
and get people's reactions. You know?
Let's just take random
pics with people in public.
So that's what we did. He
made a video on his phone.
I made a video on my phone.
Later that night I dropped
the video on TikTok
and I woke up early the next morning
and it was already at 2 million views.
And I feel like it blew so
fast. Like all the positivity.
- I literally, I could
watch it over and over.
It's amazing.
So Kitrel and Amir,
this has led to like a true
friendship as well, right?
- Yes. Yes ma'am. It definitely did.
My dad always told me, like,
I always knew how to pick
my friends and you know,
you can always tell
genuine people. You know?
- Yeah.
- [Kitrel] And it's just so crazy
how the whole thing went down.
But like, in our city,
like a lot of people
don't support each other.
So for us to get together
and support and you know,
love each other how we do, like family.
- Yeah.
- [Kitrel] I'm just, I just can't wait
to see what we have in
store for the future.
- [Kelly] I love that!
(cheering and clapping)
- [Amir] I met them and it's just crazy
how we all went together, did a video
and put smiles on people's
faces. Our vibe was there
and I'm excited for the future
and what's the outcome from it.
- Oh my God. You are bringing so much joy.
And by the way, thank you guys.
Thank you PJ, Kitrel, and Amir!
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all y'all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson show.
They want to honor ultimate overachievers,
just like you, people that
make us laugh and smile.
So they're going to be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars to
split amongst the three of you!
(cheering)
- Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
- All right y'all! Thank you so much!